Good morning, John, it's Monday March 26th. I hope you're feeling better. Last I heard you were, and if you're not
you will be soon. I mean, ah...
This is awesome.
MUSIC: Mr. T Experience - Thank You (For Not Being One of Them)
#You're so swell#
#And I can tell#
#You love me, amazingly#
#And I love you as well#
#Day by day#
#Come what may#
#You don't hesitate to exaggerate#
#And say that it's okay#
#Everybody else is trying to push me around#
#Kicking me and picking on me, running me down#
#Knocking off my glasses and stomping them into the ground#
#When they've been doing it again#
#I've got to thank you for not being one of them#
#Thank you for not being one of them#
#As it stands#
#There's still a chance#
#You'll hear me calling as I'm crawling#
#From the garbage cans#
#The kids are having fun#
#Proud of what they've done#
#Later that night we hold each other tight#
#And plot their destruction.#
#Hey hey f*ggot hey cry baby cry #
#I hate them all and I want them to die#
#You whisper to me sweet techniques we could murder them by#
#When they've been doing it again#
#I've got to thank you for never joining in#
#Thank you for not being one of them#
#Oh! Oh-uh-oh#
#Uh-oh-uh-oh#
#Oh-uh-oh#
#Wuh-oh-uh-oh#
Get well soon.
I'm going to eat this clove of garlic.
Yeah.
-Kind of hurts.
-Yeah, I don't think I'm going to be kissing him for quite a long long time.
Ahhh!
Oh My God! I think I just saw God.
Okay, John! We really hope your eyeball gets better.
- Yep.
- Okay. Bye.
- See you later. Oh my God!
Look guys! Look what I've got on my head!
Ron! No!
[Bafta-worthy overdramatic sounds of suffocation]
[Gasp] He's dead!
Noooooooo!